trevor bauer in his last start gave up
three runs on three solo home runs and
is now about 17 of them this year that's
the second most in the national league
and extra worth talking about because
he's facing the lineup that leads the
majors in home runs yeah 65 percent of
his runs that he's given up this year
are on home runs but lately i would say
the achilles heel has been not only the
home run but the loss of command at
times and the walks two and oh the count
that boat is smoked down the right field
line lookie bets hustles over to cut it
off and wade will turn it first and hold
with a single
strike recall angel hernandez goes a
foot off of the plate to ring up posey
first strikeout of the game second out
of the first alex dickerson coming up
one ball one strike
he lines one on one hop
fielded by justin turner on the first
base side of second the shift was on
dickerson had it right to him
no runs one hit after the first half of
the first giants nothing and the dodgers
are coming up on the mound for the
giants anthony d stefani who
he's been an all-star outside of the 10
runs that he gave up against the dodgers
on may 23rd you get rid of that he's got
a 180 era dodgers trying to keep things
rolling offensively with mookie betts to
lead it off
[Applause]
going into the big series your first
hitter does that max muncie who has
terrorized the giants
[Applause]
strike three threw a great one there
that
dived at the last minute straight down
below the knees two down first strikeout
for d stovanti that's how you get
bellinger company he swings and hits a
ground ball to the left side cutting
over from third as flores he's got it
and he throws to first in time for round
number three we'll give anthony
diescovany credit there he had to be
rattled after those first two hitters
now he swings and pulls this one on the
ground third base side and it goes by
the reach of justin turner into left
field base hit for wilmer flores
turner just couldn't quite get there
four is it first one gone seven pitch to
stephen duggar
got him with a change up
so the updated change up scoreboard
trevor bauer's seven strikeouts on the
change walker bueller three first and
second two gone and a two nothing game
bauer de beast
with a one-two pitch
he
[Applause]
wade single to right in his first stat
back waiting for the two on pitch and he
swings it's a high fly ball right field
bets going back mookie betts all the way
at the wall will leap and he can't get
it it's gone lamont way junior
has hit a home run against bauer to put
the giants on the board
his sixth of the year it's 2-1 dodgers
fastball driven down the right field
line a fair ball
heading for the corner
betts has got a pretty strong arm buster
will easily though make it into seconds
standing up with a double
one two [ __ ]
curl falls over the outside corner to
ring them up
the fourth for bauer two gone in the
third
as crawford grounds it
right into the glove of chris taylor
playing in short right crawford is
retired and the inning is over
that's the board muncie up here it comes
swinging a miss he got him to chase the
slider down and in strike three
beautifully thrown first and second for
the dodgers with two out here's diesel
funnies 3-2
it is hit high in the air left field not
deep dickerson coming in and he'll make
the catch for out number three
see
no problem
and so now the giants have first and
second but here's decliffany
puts this one down to muncie goes to
third they get the lead man
max muncie continues to be aggressive
charges in and plays that one and they
get the runner at third is stefani is
aboard down here's lamont wade he's just
swinging the back great here he comes
comes back
for strike three no runs two hits two
left after three and a half it's the
dodgers two and the giants won will
smith lead it off rounded out his first
time on the first pitch that he saw
high fly ball to deep left field back
towards the wall will smith leaves the
yard
third solo home run tonight for the
dodgers they lead it 3-1
[Applause]
2-2 and he tied him up he swung strike
three hernandez made the call
2-2 pitch swing and a miss a high
fastball struck him out very similar to
the pitch with which he struck him out
in the second inning
trevor bauer
six strikeouts one walk and a solo home
run to lamont wade junior
so now crawford leads off against trevor
bauer giants have some work to do they
trail 3-1 crawford maybe started that
work
deep center field and gone way out of
here
wow what a home run brandon crawford and
the giants are back to within one his
17th of the year
404
feet and the o2 pitch
swing and there's a drive left center
field going back still going back honey
ooh and i beg your pardon off the top of
the wall i was a little over excited on
that one i believe it was off the top of
the wall
and uh it stayed in the yard into second
flores with a double tight run at second
two gone bauer comes home
[Applause]
eight strikeouts for power
victor coming in here still continuing
to work towards the consistency he had
last year but still a very dominant
season here comes an 0-2
gonzalez strikes him
and buster drills one into left field
that's going to be a hit for posey one
hop to pollock who's over to cut it off
before it gets through into the alleyway
but posey's got another hit he's two for
four
and the giants have two on
little check swing number gonzalez has
to hurry froze to first gets crawford
and his inning is over
the backup catcher for the giants being
sent up there as a pinch hitter the
tying run at third and the go ahead run
in second
a chase and a wicked slider two gone in
the eighth
here's a 2-1
[Applause]
this month hasn't given up an earned run
here's his 3-1 to talkman
[Applause]
and to center bellinger has to play it
on a bounce and he gets by him
momentarily tuckman headed for second
defender
dickerson grounds it to second base
taylor from short right field picks it
up throws them out the dodgers win it
three to two